The idea of free college got a lot of
attention during the 2016 election. Now,
it sounds pretty progressive, but what
many people don't know is that students
from rich families are the ones who
stand to benefit the most. Consider what
happened when Oregon passed a free
community college program. The average
poor student got just six hundred
dollars out of the program, but the
average rich student got nearly
twenty-five hundred dollars. That's right -
rich
students got four times as much money as
poor students out of free community college.
Now, the reason for this is that we
already have lots of programs to help
lower-income students afford college.
For instance, the Pell Grant program
gives students from poor families up to
fifty-eight hundred dollars to help them
pay for college. That's enough to pay
tuition and then some at many community
colleges. That means poor students pay
much less tuition than rich students,
once you factor in financial aid. It's no
surprise that when you get rid of
tuition rich students are the big
winners. Don't you think we could spend
that money better somewhere else?
To learn more about my take on free college,
check out the links in the description
below. Also, let us know what other topics
you want a AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.